oh mein gott hab ich ein glück gehabt
also und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut ich habe mich am bock auf das
heutige video denn es geht mal wieder um
mein auto ich habe mein neues auto erst
seit etwas über einem monat
und ich habe das bei meinem letzten auto
aufgemacht habe ich nach einem oder zwei
monaten so wir haben eine erfahrung mit
euch geteilt und das hat mir mal eine
menge spaß gemacht das machen wir heute
wieder
ich muss direkt am anfang ich sagen ich
bin kein kfz mechaniker ich bin auch
kein auto die also wenn irgendwas falsch
rüber kommen nimmt mir bitte nicht diese
ja das tut mir einen trotzdem gebe ich
mein bestes und ich hoffe ihr habt spaß
beim video
wir fahren jetzt erst mal los kurz auto
waschen weil ich muss das mal waschen
das ist ein bisschen lesen kann sehen
wir uns im auto wieder letzter sodann
mal rein
also der einstieg ist wirklich immer das
an strengste ich dachte da werde ich mir
derzeit besser an besser drin aber
irgendwie überhaupt nicht es ist jedes
mal einfach dieses sollte ich mir jetzt
angekommen beim autowaschen und machen
wir mal das ist jetzt wirklich auf das
erste mal dass ihn wasche ganz schön
dreckig schon es geht doch eigentlich
nicht
[Musik]
also leute auto ist wieder halbwegs
sauber ist nicht perfekt geworden aber
das reicht auf jeden fall erstmal ich
habe mir noch so für die felgen sollen
mittel bestellt was man da drauf
springen kann ist noch nicht angekommen
aber beim nächsten mal gar nicht dass
dann benutzen wenn auf jeden fall
zufrieden so das reicht schon
ach so und in muss ich eigentlich auch
noch machen das mache ich in ruhe später
den muss dann habe ich immer durch die
waschstraße geschickte habt ihr immer
gemeckert dass ich das wird er nicht
machen soll
aber hiermit machen wir das jetzt nicht
mehr genug gewaschen ich will euch jetzt
mehr vom auto zeigen da freue ich mich
sehr drauf wir fahren jetzt zum coolen
ort und sehen uns dann da wieder ganz
entspannt hier im elektromodus niemand
hört was ich habe auch schon von vielen
unis komplimente bekommen und das auto
ist aber schön und so schön leise also
mit dem auto kommt ist eigentlich
überall gut weg außer bei den leuten die
meinen untermotorisiert aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen für mich ist das das
perfekte auto ich bereue es überhaupt
nicht dass ich dieses auto habe es macht
mir so unfassbar viel spaß hier ist die
ganze zeit 30
das ist wirklich so du du bist halt wenn
du einmal an tipp
domain gehört habe ich ein glück gehabt
alter habt ihr es gesehen ich bin gerade
noch so schön ohne scheiß wäre der fall
wenn ich 30 war nicht was 240 gefahren
und dann stand da einfach die polizei
und ich habe abgewogen ist einmal kurz
drauf gedrückt dann war ich so bei 45
das war auch schon nach der messung
alter hey wie kann man sein glück gehabt
der tag für ihn ganz gut an heute
okay wir sind da leute gebt euch meister
wunderschön hier
wir sind hier einfach irgendwo ja ich
muss nur zehn minuten herausfahren aus
meiners video und dann hast du dort
heftigste dorf wo niemand ist und was
man auch dazusagen muss das auto jetzt
hier so im gras sie auch schon sehr sehr
nice mit der wäsche bin ich jetzt
halbwegs zufrieden da muss ich noch ein
bisschen üben aber gut ihr habt ja
sicherlich schon gemerkt so ich bin
wirklich sehr sehr glücklich mit dem
auto und ich freue mich jedes mal wenn
ich da einsteigen kann und damit fahren
kann ich habe viele videos gesehen in
dem es darum geht ja das auto hatten
ziemlich ziemlich hohen preis also wenn
man den neukauf liegt er so weit ich
glaube der lag bei 147 1000 also ich hab
dann natürlich nicht gekauft dass wir
auch an sich zu viel geld für mich und
ich würde so viel geld niemals für ein
auto ausgeben habe ich auch schon gesagt
und ich habe viele videos gesehen wo das
auto stark kritisiert wird und ja das
ist halt so teuer ist für die leistung
und das was es somit bringt vielleicht
ziehe ich dieses video auch ein bisschen
so auf ob es sich halt für den preis
meine meinung nach lohnt
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen im vergleich
zu mustern klar ist es ein ganz anderes
auto ein ganz anderes fahrgefühl das
auto liegt viel sicher auf der straße
ich fühle mich viel sicherer damit du
fährst 210 220 und es kommt mir vor als
würde 150 fahren für mich ist es ein
absolutes traumauto und ich würde nicht
sagen dass es den preis nicht gerecht
wird ich bin noch nie in meinem leben
sondern geiles auto gefahren und da halt
jeden morgen einsteigen zu können ist
einfach unfassbar geiles gefühl ist
vielleicht schon ein bisschen schade
dass das mein alltagsauto ist und man
halt vielleicht mit der zeit so ein
bisschen dieses besondere verlieren aber
jetzt habe ich eigentlich genug gelabert
also ich habe mir ein paar vor und
nachteile aufgeschrieben was ich
persönlich mega cool findet klar
vielleicht ist auch nur mein geschmack
aber wir haben hier vorne den
elektromotor mit 143 ps ist vielleicht
ein bisschen schade das war nur bis 55
kilometer rein elektrisch fahren kann
aber wenn ich halt bei mir einfach in
der stadt ein bisschen rum fahren als
meinen eltern wieder zurück zu meiner
wohnung man verbraucht halt sehr wenig
sprit weil sehr oft halt einfach der e
motor nur beansprucht wird ich glaube
ich habe jetzt 1800 kilometer runter und
tanken war ich ja auf jeden fall nicht
so viel wie mit den mustern was ich ganz
gut auch sagen wollte uns war der tank
um fast 40 liter
das auto war komplett voll und auch voll
elektrisch aufgeladen
also ich damals aus münchen abgeholt
habe als ich hier ankam hatte ich ein
durchschnittsverbrauch auf der strecke
von 7,1 liter er liegt jetzt
mittlerweile bei über acht ich muss aber
auch sagen dass ich den e-motor jetzt
schon zwei wochen nicht mehr aufgeladen
habe also der pendelt immer so zwischen
1 kilometer reichweite und sieben
kilometer reichweite je nachdem wie ich
halt gefahren bin ja wollte ich
unbedingt aussage hier hinten haben wir
dann stehen verbrenner motor gut fällt
wahrscheinlich schon so die nächste
sache auf also hier sitzt darunter wir
haben nur einen ganz ganz kleinen
kofferraum hier geht wirklich gar nichts
rein also ich bin mit dem einmal zum
flughafen gefahren ich habe zum glück
nur handgepäck dabei der hat so gerade
da reingepasst das war es dann auch da
muss ich halt ganz ehrlich auch sagen
ich weiß nicht warum vorne keinen
kofferraum ist das hätte sich eigentlich
mega gut angeboten ich glaube hier ist
noch genug bleibt was ich auch extrem
feier ist einfach so diese form und
diese kleinen details akzent wie man es
auch immer nennen mag wir gehen bei
einer kurz rein ich zeige euch was ich
meine du sitzt am lenkrad guckst in
spiegel und sie ist daran so diesen ich
nenne jetzt mal windkanal
wo also der wind durch geht ich finde
das sieht einfach so sportlich aus zu
geil viele denken auch er ist sein
kofferraum auf ein bisschen sieht so aus
dass wir der kofferraum auf na ja gut
ich mach dir mal kurz an ein paar sachen
habe ich nämlich auch hier die ich sagen
muss habe ich sehr oft auch unter meinen
die du zu dem auto gelesen dass viele
meinen
die innenausstattung ist absolut weg für
den preis kann ich ein bisschen
nachvollziehen also das sieht jetzt
wirklich nicht besonders aus wobei ich
also mir reicht es allemal so ist ein
sportwagen
und ich habe noch keine funktion hier
vermisst die ich irgendwie gerne hätte
du konstant ihre war eigentlich alles
steuern auch die sprachsteuerung ist
super das navigationssystem habe ich bei
meinem mustang immer über apple kabel
gesteuert weil es halt einfach so auf
irgendwelche fehler hatte und ich bin
zwei mal am falschen ort gelangt da
dachte ich mir so ey du benutzt das
jetzt nicht mehr das bmw navi absolut
nice du kannst einfach das navi im head
up display sehen ihr wart immer
navigation nach hause sagen oder wählen
und dann wird das hier im head up
display angezeigt wo man lang fahren
musst du kannst ja sogar die straße
sehen also da wird auch die maps oder
eingescannt das hat mich wirklich sehr
begeistert ach so was auch sehr wild ist
du kannst ja auch dieses p drücken und
dann kriegst du so eine animierte
ansicht von einem fahrzeuge wie es
draußen also zum partner als eine kleine
park hilfe hier sieht man jetzt zum
beispiel das maisfeld hier ist der weg
ist auch krass alter und es hilft schon
manchmal das kann man schon sagen
also auffahrunfall beim parken ist
eigentlich unmöglich da ja genau und
vorne ist auch neue kamera drin
also du hast auf jeden fall rundum
ansicht das ist nicht schlecht
damals brauch ich brauche eigentlich
nicht eine sache auf die ich doch gar
nicht angegangen bin die mich auch
einfach ja die mir einfach spaß macht
und zwar das sind natürlich die türen
die so schön jeweils auf der fahrerseite
also auf der beifahrerseite ganz
entspannt zur seite aufgehen für mich
ist das schon fast so normal geworden
man denkt so irgendwie ja dass bei jedem
auto so aber ist es natürlich nicht
das ist einfach sehr sehr lustig ist
auch viele denkmal muss den knopf
drücken dann gehen die automatisch auch
wieder zu das ist leider nicht so man
muss sich selber zu ziehen so ein scheiß
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich noch
irgendwas vergessen habe zu sagen ich
glaube das waren jetzt erstmal so die
sachen die mir in diesem monat
aufgefallen ist sowohl positiv als auch
negativ
es gibt natürlich noch viele viele
andere sachen jedes auto mitbringt wenn
ihr sagt mach mal mehr dazu schreibt
gerne in die kommentare dann mache ich
vielleicht mal so videos 10 dinge die
ich an g8 liebe und zehn dinge die ich
nicht so cool finden oder irgendwie so
da gibt es auf jeden fall eine menge was
man da machen kann gesamtfazit von mir
absolutes traumauto ich bin so zufrieden
dass nach mir so unfassbar viel spaß und
ja ich bin noch nie irgendwie lambo
gefahren oder sowas deswegen vielleicht
liegt es auch daran dass ich gar nicht
sagen auszusetzen habe dass ich nicht
sage er die leistung für den preis ist
zu gering oder so aber mich macht das
auto recht jeden tag aufs neue so ein
bisschen glücklich und darum geht's ja
auch irgendwie ich hoffe es hat euch
einigermaßen gefallen wie gesagt wenn
einiges jetzt so ein bisschen schwammig
war
ich bin kein auto pro ich hoffe ihr
nehmt mir nicht übel ich dachte aber
einfach das schade wäre das nicht zu
machen und ja ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen abonniert sehr gern den kanal
wir sehen uns morgen 19 wir gibt's neues
video das was von mir
haut rein